can't do that can't embed to you guys so
when lying backstage to see Branson
15,000 people gonna be crazy I realized
I'm in the wrong time zone got your
little too early presentation boonie
boots we need food let's get food
alright just got to the convention
center have to go sign in get my badge
so happy last night that baby did not
wake up had a pretty solid sleep much
better than I expected so I'm happy
about that look up just a couple minutes
before my alarm so this apparently is
the largest convention center in the
world which is pretty impressive so I'm
going to go get my badge and then
excited to see you know Stephen Kelly
mean which brings me
super jive huge room let's go 360
look at this look at this look at that
15,000 people gonna be praised
this man grew right there have a social
media Christine this is andres hi guys
executive executive the human pally
business executive presence is like in
the Stephen Kelly 11 the man here is a
visionary serving a visionary visionary
serving another vision when lying
backstage to see Branson by the coleman
and i'll add the bring the Camerons
some strict contract that they have into
has some shots our feet 2060 SH very
cloudy day with some passionate about
you are you gonna start a bad check
gotta get rid of the etely join me and
got a battle so fresh fish so I realized
I'm in the wrong time zone got you a
little too early for my presentation
I got a little more time to do my stuff
so first one is I love 15 and mine's a
1230 raising capital so I still got time
see my phone let me show you
this is 1203 so impulsive be here half
an hour really to get ready and setups
like rushing to get it but I actually
have a little bit of time to explore get
some food people are pouring in such a
just finished it's time to get some food
and they get ready to do some
presentation at the channel Rosa
rosalina Moses mad
ah what do I do so I creature all right
yeah this is good look at that yeah so
it's for the
virtual card
okay so no guys come on where's the
coercive guys do some guys push into a
mattress
Chicago was with you too
we have another fan help people men and
women don't give you like
my name is ISA Camille yeah just saw
Evan I think a few weeks ago amazing guy
authentic sincere I mean as a speaker I
mean you don't find it out of authentic
speak without them go behind the scene
in the green room Thomas cameras how the
Yemen is real so check it out I gotta
bring you with me everywhere we need
boots we need food let's get food so the
time of different food options here we
got the Italian station American station
down there more American station this is
all food it's crazy we got to eat all
right I had a great lunch good
conversation belly full of food and I'm
ready to go hit the stage at the right
time super excited to be here sage
summit my second time here today talking
about raising capital okay so I'm
definitely session I ended up talking to
people for an hour and 15 minutes
afterwards and basically ran over and
tired the other guys entire session he
kept having a movie over and over and
over
more because of people that want to chat
which is super flattering awesome a
bunch of fans that I already knew about
me and got the meet for the first time
which is awesome and a bunch of new
people who had never heard of me before
and I'm now going to check out channel
always such a high to go to meet fans
punch burners and save them time and
help them and know that they're going to
like take that knowledge and go and
drive it into the business always just
makes me come alive and super excited
for thursday we're going to be talking
about marketing and yeah can't wait to
do it so pump soap up always in such a
rush man helping entrepreneurs the
biggest rush in the world so pop I found
the plug power bar that could plug my
camera into my computer so I'm going to
do some filming for the channel what's
up it's actually hard here because
everything is covered up actually get
access so I'm going to
and supper corner with channel live from
safe summit thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe I read just
finished filming my videos so far around
1 i'm gonna have to do this in two shots
a bunch of background noise and had to
leave to go to different location but
getting there getting there getting
there it's what five o'clock now i'm
going to head back to the hotel check in
on Nina see how she's doing and to some
email do some tweets watch some videos
because they need to review those for
you guys that we keep the schedule up
otherwise you'll freak out what happened
a week and no videos can't do that you
can't do that to you guys and then I
have a meeting at eight o'clock dinner
with some of the social media guys here
I'd say there should be some fun times
and keep you posted
I love it when they have Wi-Fi on buses
can send some messages to Nina checking
out email not just killing time and
stuff dude beautiful day here should
have really feeling it but I got to get
inside the hotel Christine I messaged me
that maybe the checking on some videos
urgently so she can get editing on them
so that you guys have something to watch
so that's what I'm going to do for the
next two hours and then head off to
dinner
alright have a good session got a little
bit of work done not as much as I would
have wanted also passed out tired today
just a lot out of me but whatever you
know I needed a nap i guess so now i'm
heading out to dinner with the i forget
the official titles so exactly the vice
president of marketing for sage
basically the number three guy at sage
and some other people some of the other
influencers we're going to a steakhouse
and I want to walk it as much as
possible when i get a city I'd much
rather walk then take the bus to take
the subway take a cab sometimes it's not
always doable sometimes just too far
sometimes you in a rush none of this
rain each other that's too hot but
beautiful night like this I just like
seeing the scene of city experiencing
the vibe on foot maybe it's my thing I
don't know when you travel it you'd
rather walk or subway so it means it
takes a little extra time to get there
but enough I like the experience so time
to watch chicago and then get some state
I just got stopped on the street by
Paolo Paolo what's that man a man just
want to say you were amazing thank you
so much for all the videos you know you
inspire me every single day so I have to
stop by and say hello love it one of the
business really so I'm building a
messaging app for sports okay where
people came talk about life events okay
and we are almost like 1 million users
and I want to and I'll share with you
and are you going to take a look and see
because you have a great vision for what
its successes and intrapreneurship
chairman and you know look me up send me
an email you can find me on my website
hanging out okay cheers bro
alright this is the place gene and
giorgetti Chicago's finest since
nineteen forty one
here's our team canada in the house pan
in the house i write most of our table
is here have an attack yeah hey guys are
interrupting my session yeah I'm
starting off with with a chicago-based
IPA super excited to give that a shot
i'm going to try some Tebow this steak
is bigger than your head there's no way
he's gonna be like legitimately that's
gonna do man true yeah the termination
stay I finish my thighs person to myself
I'm tapping out I can't handle this
ginormous take all right we were the
last ones in the restaurant what time is
it which I was lazy it's like 11 it's a
love it love it that's 11 I feel like
it's 11 you got to wake up 15 to try
this we gotta wake up when we got to
wake up tomorrow we have to be a back of
the conference at nine thirty tomorrow
morning for the keynote oh wait that's
not that bad actually 930 right yeah but
we gotta wake up and get going so what
benign for Gwyneth Paltrow is zooey
deschanel we're gonna cram how many
people into an uber fine why I'm gonna
try to get in they feel like I'm saying
think you can see we feel like I'm small
apparently i know very small I go first
small goes flat shoes off I'm six-foot
skinny so they feel like believe this
but the flat shoes is right you're at
the reading Jason
so we're gonna take an uber back to the
hotel and then I still got I still got
work to do yeah i got a chance for this
i got at least yeah i have to do an
Instagram and a dweet what's not here to
work okay this isn't just social hairy
man we're here to win hi I'm number 22
Richard Branson I got to change that
apparently us what he told me we're
having a fun time and sage so much [ __ ]
our uber is here we're gonna we're going
to cram in I feel like I should get in
first which I get my spot we don't have
a goober in Vancouver yeah very cool
Vancouver's a little behind oh come on
well it is I get lots of legroom in the
front okay we're talking back we're safe
we're saving